this is walnut in rain what the hell's
on my head
Jason oh no yeah you did you gave it to
me Oh No hipster god damn trucker hat no
I if my hair is like just looking really
flat and ugly I'm always like dim a hat
because I like P pros like oh he's
insecure nice going bald I know I've
been going ball for a while but like if
it's like really flat I'll just say if
it's like that I hate that cuz it really
looks like there's nothing there already
so that's the only hat I own as I bunch
of ever wear this I look ridiculous this
way then the other way it isn't actual
it's not a hipster hat it's actually
from when I was a kid and I was in Boy
Scouts it was a little close there
Leslie and it was a whole week long
thing that's really awesome
I miss it yeah Oh actually hold on
usually have to wait a little bit before
we get distracted but no we got
detective right away Oh give me that
shit
what oh I don't care kick that shit I'm
totally wearing this yes good oh there's
so much better and so much more fur feel
it that way yeah see I don't just watch
adventure time I actually have wear own
at this camera everything we do is like
flipped so I'm just like this okay
so Finn tell me about this episode
you're doing something bad aren't you
I'm a good boy
yeah see if you can see is Toby
something yeah okay that should be good
you know you're fine I think yeah but
it's so I love it I like it right I'll
I'll do Jake justice Jake's this as I
like to call it okay in my head yeah you
can wear that one no change do you have
here to cover my beautiful beautiful
need to showered hair okay
uh welcome super Hey here we go I'll
just start the video there that's where
I should start but okay so this is a
episode where Finn and Jake the Finn
falls down one hole Jake falls down
another and Finn is in the presence of
this giant who just sort of sits there
and does nothing and lets his little
food minions feed him and do all this
stuff and I wants Finn to stay there and
then Jake falls on this very slow
falling platform that this bear is put
together named seven seven one eight or
bill backwards and then they kind of
make a friendship there and eventually
they come in contact with each other and
they help each other out and they get
out and bill has a hot dog even though
it's bull stuff but he don't give up
yeah Jude is too vulgar boots that's
right yeah yeah that's too vulgar for
this meal so uh this is again this is a
cute episode um it reminds me a lot of
like it felt like sort of three classic
fairy tales sort of thrown into each
other cat felt like Jack and the
Beanstalk but then like well Aesop
fables with like maybe don't cry wolf or
something like that um but it's like I
don't know it felt it felt like I had
that vibe but it was still original
enough it's like okay this is like its
own thing it's not like oh this is just
a combination of these three or four
like it still kind of feels like its own
thing you know obviously don't just sit
around and do nothing get up and do
stuff and especially don't kidnap people
while you're doing that
oh he's the kid lesson for the kids so
many young kidnappers out there shoot
systems released those kids then ah hey
doing they breathe you brainwashed her
well get back to work so uh yeah the
stuff I probably like the most honestly
it's kind of shame it's these two
stories because the one with Finn is
fine I almost just wanted to be with
Jake and Bill then like one that kind of
be a fun episode if it was nothing but
them falling and working off of each
other and talking to each other actually
I liked it better when
you don't see anything then it comes
back and they're dancing around with the
cards and it's like you do wonder how it
got there but it's probably incredibly
boring getting up to there it also
wasn't that long amount of time it took
you're at a party and you know you're
drinking and everything and you come
into a room and people are already
plastered and they're having a blast
well the beginning wasn't a blast it's
over time that you start having more fun
and now I'm not advocating getting
wasted or anything I am but I'm drunk
right now I also want to wear this but
no it's like uh I don't know I kind of
like the whole idea of kind of coming in
and going what the heck happened uh and
imagining how it got there instead of
knowing well that's me though well no
and it's fine too cuz you know that bill
has not seen a person for god knows how
long I mean he said it could be weeks
that you've been falling yeah cuz even
he's forgotten the amount of time and
the funny thing about the character is
that you know it could either be he's
been down there for so long that he's
just kind of lost his mind a little bit
which is understandable or maybe he's
just always been kind of Loony cuz like
you know Jake fell and landed um pretty
quick you know Finn hasn't been down
there for weeks or anything like that so
maybe he was just already a little kooky
you know first thing wants to do we get
it sup there's Emma hot dog um I
actually don't mind hot dogs you like
hot dogs right yes you know they get a
bad rap you know it's a good shape
plenty of protein cheap you must have
seen that happening come on the hot dogs
see you've never seen the happening why
would i watch an M night Rumble oh my
god you can see that happening I'm sorry
this is really good this is worth T
trailing the V lock is amazing it's one
of like the funniest movies ever made
even though it's not meant to be funny
I just heard Mark Wahlberg like doesn't
like phone it in he's just kind of like
and starts dialing and that he stops
know everything everything he talks
about it's exactly like this just do you
know what that Donnie peas are missing
the honey bees guys where are they
so am i watching that's just fucking
great sadly I own it but I never was oh
gotta watch it gotta watch it
screw the V logs looks a little few log
on the happening happening B launches
every 10 minutes what the hell is going
on this makes no sense
um I should be kind of fun maybe we have
an idea but uh okay so uh but yeah I I
thought this was this is a cute episode
I love the design of those weird food
yeah
whatever those were the watermelon and
steak it's like yeah cuz those would go
together
um loudly dude I was wondering where
they were gonna go with his plan that
really elaborate crazy plan that starts
to work and then just like it goes a
different dress
yeah cuz at first I thought like he was
just gonna be like you know he
complements them they untie him and then
he shoots the arrow and hits this bird
that's gonna hit the asparagus and do
the Domino thing I thought he was gonna
like compliment them or whatever ask
them a question they're just gonna be
like nope and they like couldn't even
get the starting point going but I kind
of like that they do kind of like the
half-wave yeah please for a reason I
didn't see it coming
yeah so uh yeah what are your thoughts
as you would say with most episodes a
very basic episodes I can't read it too
much into it I mean I could probably dig
for something like oh actually I see
this as a way of commenting on communism
no I'm gonna maybe the way the King ran
things I'm like that was like shit did I
actually come you might have actually
come and actually could kind of work um
no I was if anything it's like yeah get
off your ass and don't just sit there
you know even if you don't have to get
up hmm you know you should get up every
once in a while and do something yeah
you know well if anything I mean
especially I found out that you know if
you're working on something and you're
stuck and you want to be funny or more
clever something like this you gotta
move around if you just sit in one spot
like it will
you know to get the blood flowing and
everything just you can't think more
abstractly you can't think these are
failing yeah do anything we just sit
here yes but it's okay they do the work
for us there you go I'm tired that's why
you need to boost them they get tired
too fast
and these that oh this is an interesting
episode of adventure time I've never
seen this foot this is live action
what no okay it's a cute episode um like
I said I wouldn't mind seeing more bill
he was just strange enough voice by
Chris Isaak yeah oh we found out where
there was I'm like I know that name I
looked him up he's like he's in the love
stuff that I didn't know he was in he
did all this music I didn't know it's
like why do I know this name and then I
tried to sing and I'm a terrible singer
but just like him and you actually have
pretty good I just want to say I was
mocked for it this is what rightfully so
yeah yeah no and then what we heard the
song it's like oh that was actually a
really good impression I do love that
bill falling down the vent he's not
actually falling he hasn't been falling
at all yeah it's um parachute ya know
it's like cuz they've just been sitting
there cuz he keeps rising
so he's been going no way oh man I
didn't catch on to okay no I always like
he was just very slowly going and we
didn't know how far up like the chimney
was or what that's what no that makes
that they would just be floating there
and then when it came loose that's when
they fell yeah okay that makes sense and
he's like I've been here for I don't
know how long and it's it's funny
because yeah once the heat cuts out also
don't like who cuz that's how it works
god that's almost like that's almost
like some sort of Greek mythology or
something like that you can all tell
like the guy that just was always
falling even though he never was falling
except he would go until like he either
dies or feels more cruel it'd be like he
lives for eternity just there like
always waiting to hit the bottom herself
like that only guy rolling the boulder
up there yeah yeah we Gregson later then
yeah so no I didn't catch on to that
that's very interesting
that was my favorite cuz it was just
like you see them dancing and also in
the heat cuts out there like dinner do
well so no I trying to think what people
are gonna gripe about me not catching us
not catching I hope I see more bill I
like to bill I love to see or seven I'm
sorry okay his name is seven yeah guy
guy said I did love the way he counted
though dreamy three thousand one
Mississippi eight hundred and forty
seven thousand Mississippi but that got
really boring
freecell everyone played free so
apparently it was yeah there was one
point where he's talking about free
selling he like sounds so weird but yeah
like looks at the camera directly he's
like free sells a great game good back
to it like I'm like is he being paid by
free cell which is not actually a
company so yeah good episode I
definitely liked it you know nothing too
big or huge to say about except it can
really inspire you to watch the
happening and get up you don't do things
don't be lazy like me so if I also go
put on there happening now you couldn't
do anything about it alphabetical yeah
but like where's the a no that's only L
through Z